et puis tu te fais à l'idée que tu
sortiras plus jamais d'ici mais tout à
coup un jour il t'arrive quelque chose
qui te rappelle qui tu étais
je suis pas un criminel je peux pas
prendre 6 ans pour ça ça n'a aucun sens
[Musique]
tu es dans ma cellule et ici on fait ce
que je dis mais toi pourquoi tu es là ça
se demande pas
[Applaudissements]
il faudra pas longtemps pour devenir
comme moi approche-toi regarde
vous n'êtes pas comme eux
on est en démocratie maintenant
réponse on a créé la coordination des
prisonniers en lutte
tous les prisonniers ont le droit de
s'évader
[Musique]
je veux que tu m'inscrives à ton espèce
de syndical je veux sortir d'ici
qu'est-ce que tu fais une mutinerie
on compte plus pour personne
[Musique]
ce pays est fait pour les fils de patron
si le pays doit repartir à zéro nous
aussi on fera pareil moi je te crois
rien ne changera jamais
parce qu'on va s'évader
[Applaudissements]
je vous enferme tous dehors les fils de